sur le canton
de hérouville et de colombelles une
victoire une victoire que je n'attendais
pas aussi aussi importante près de 59%
dès le deuxième tour cela montre encore
une fois cette politique de proximité
j'ai pu initier ces quatre dernières
semaines il fallait rendre compte bien
sûr sur un bilan en tant que maire mais
aussi en tant que conseiller
départemental et le travail a été fait
particulièrement en direction des
colombelloises et de colombellois parce
qu'on a vraiment un tableau senti une
détresse une détresse sur lequel
malheureusement le département où le
conseiller général précédente n'a pas dû
pu prendre la mesure est elle que ce
soit sur l'emploi sur le cadre de vie
sur la formation et sur l'habitat par
exemple on sent un ras-le-bol un
désintérêt total de donner des élections
en général et s'est traduit au travers d
abstention ce soir et la semaine
dernière donc à nous de d'essayer de
rendre l'engagement politique dans le
bon sens du terme avec des valeurs au
delà des clivages politiques les les
habitants en ont ras-le-bol en marre de
ce clivage gauche droite entre l'ump ps
les habitants veulent un autre discours
une autre approche une entente les
écouter et malheureusement on le voit
dans les débats nationaux
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va redorer le
blason du politique en soi et c'est à
nous localement je pense que je suis
persuadé par expérience maintenant que
tout passera sur le local est justement
au niveau local au niveau départemental
vous allez rejoindre un conseil
départemental qui garde sa majorité à
droite c'était important oui parce que
et je les dis je les rappeler pendant
cette campagne à l'ensemble des
habitants d'hérouville de colombelles
tout ce qu'a pu apporter le département
autant de à d'ornano est aujourd'hui
avec jean léonce dupont qui a apporté
des réponses sur la rénovation urbaine
sur l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle sur l'emploi le
développement économique on dit souvent
que la ville d'hérouville a changé et
c'est une fierté pour moi bien sûr
depuis que je suis maire mais sans le
département vous m'entendez bien sans le
département nous n'en serions pas là
parce que le département a bien compris
de la situation économique et sociale
dire aux villes et bien le conseiller
général que je suis que j'ai été donc
depuis maintenant 2008 a essayé
d'apporter des réponses et ses réponses
assez concrétisé sur des actions
justement pour lutter contre contre le
chômage dans les quartiers les plus
défavorisés sur la rénovation urbaine
comme je le disais sur le transport tout
ça mis bout à bout il ya des piliers
comme je dis souvent qui sont
fondamentaux et ce à quoi je me suis
toujours battue et je compte bien sûr
continuer cette belle aventure mais mais
sans aucune posture individuel moi ce
que je veux c'est de faire partager
partager et que ne surtout pas baisser
les bras et qu'il y à des alternatives à
condition que tout le monde allait se
rassemblent et se rassemble au delà des
clivages politiques avec un seul et même
objectif trouver des situations par
rapport à ce que peuvent subir une bonne
partie de la population en france et
particulièrement sur mon canton donc je
vais m'y atteler
pendant ces prochaines semaines
prochains mois parce que encore une fois
c'est les les électeurs m'ont fait
confiance à moi de leur rendre aussi
l'appareil est d'apporter des réponses
c'est ce à quoi je vais maquiller dès
demain matin d'ailleurs